my name is Reuben I'm a faculty member
here in two departments mechanical
engineering and engineering and public
policy and as a number of my colleagues
as well we all wear different hats in a
variety of centers and Institute's that
pull us together in in various energy
related activities so the focus of the
work we do currently here is really in
two areas at the technology level we try
to understand what the options are for
delivering energy in a form that is both
affordable and reliable but also
environmentally acceptable we look at
various technologies to address
environmental issues we look at their
economic and other impacts we look at
uncertainty in markets and in technology
performance and we try to from that
distill and identify the most productive
path to getting this ideal situation of
energy that is both clean reliable and
affordable the other major focus of the
work related to this is on technology
innovation but innovation specifically
related to environmental technologies
technologies for which there is
typically not a natural marketplace
where people are rushing to go out and
buy a new product that that they like so
we're we're very happy and proud that
much of the work we do here is having an
impact not only around the country but
around the world one of those impacts is
in the use of software that we've
developed to do analysis of complex
energy systems like electric power
plants we have a tool that thousands of
people are using to analyze options for
delivering electricity that is
affordable but also environmentally
acceptable in the context of their own
particular situation of course we
ourselves use those tools to try to
develop insights and make
recommendations both to companies and to
government and non-governmental
organizations
as to what the best pads are to pursue
to deploy technology that is again from
an energy point of view reliable and
affordable but also environmentally
clean and acceptable
you